Some things just
don't go together--
oil and water, gas and
matches, tequila and fireworks.
So you can imagine
my concern when
I heard about a combination
of kayaking and surfing.
[water waves]
Then I saw this
and thought perhaps
I'm worrying about nothing.
And then I saw this and realized
I was right the first time.
All right.
If we're going to go treating
a kayak like a surfboard,
we'd better prep on center of
buoyancy and hydrodynamic drag.
To remain stable, a kayaker
keeps the center of mass
directly over the kayak
center of buoyancy,
which is in the middle
of its submerged volume.
Traveling out to sea, it helps
to keep the kayak perpendicular
to the waves, because
turning sideways
can mean more hydrodynamic
drag and a salty roll.
When catching a wave, you must
ensure the nose doesn't dig
into the water,
otherwise the resulting
increase in hydrodynamic drag
could produce a turning effect.
Waves can travel
hundreds of miles,
relentlessly building speed
and power before smashing
into your kayak, but we
should be OK-- providing
we remember the rules.
[noise]
Hold on a minute, should we
be perpendicular to the wave
or parallel to it?
[music playing]
Yes, it was perpendicular.
By hitting the wave
almost parallel
he presents a
large surface area,
which leads to enough
hydrodynamic drag
to flip the kayak.
[music playing]
We are out and ready
to catch a wave.
I'm videoing this just in
case things don't go well.
That's a little negative.
Confident, confident.
[noise]
But well-founded.
Good start, but here the
nose digs in slows down
and our friends enjoy the
benefits of the turning effect.
Now these guys have got
it nice and perpendicular,
minimal drag.
Like a knife through
salty butter.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: Maybe it's safer
to avoid all that nasty drag
and head out of the
surf to calm open sea.
There it is.
NARRATOR: Oh, look-- a
delightful little fish.
[music playing]